je vais profiter de vous donner quelques
informations sur les mission
d'information comme ça ça permettra à
d'autres collègues de nous rejoindre
pour écouter la
parole de nos illustres invités le
bureau de la commission a souhaité créer
6 missions d'information qui
comprendrait à chaque fois 12 membres
trois députés renaissances et un député
appartenant à chacun des neuf rut de
groupe et serait systématiquement cor
rapporté par un député de la majorité un
député de l'opposition là je ne fais que
vous rappeler ce que nous avons décidé
depuis maintenant 1 an sur ces six
missions d'information je suis
aujourd'hui en mesure de vous annoncer
le thème et l'identité des deux
rapporteurs de cinq missions il s'agit à
la demande du groupe connaissance une
mission d'information portant sur
l'impact des dispositifs fiscaux et
sociaux sur le reste à vivre des
travailleurs de la classe moyenne qui
sera rapporté par Monsieur Mathieu lefè
groupe Renaissance et Madame Eva SAS
groupe écologiste à la demande du groupe
rassemblement national mission
d'information portant sur l'optimisation
financière et stratégique de l'offre
d'emploi à domicile qui sera rapporté
par Monsieur jcelin de SIG pour le
rassemblement national et Monsieur Luc
gessmar pour le groupe modem à la
demande du groupe éfinupes mission
d'information portant sur la réalité des
financements publics dans les villes
populaires qui sera rapporté par
Monsieur Sébastien Rome et les filles et
Madame Alexandra Martin groupe
Renaissance à la demande du groupe
socialiste d'une mission d'information
portant sur le dysfonctionnement et les
délais relatifs aux taxes foncière et
d'urbanisme à la taxe d'habitation sur
les résidence secondaire et les
conséquences pour les contribuables la
l'administration fiscale et les
collectivités évaluation de gérer les
biens immobiliers du foncier vant en
lien avec ces taxe sera rapporté par
Madame Christine pierrez bon groupe
socialiste et Monsieur romain Reda
groupe Renaissance à la demande du
groupe horizon du mission d'information
portant sur la fiscalité de l'épargne
par la capitalisation finançant la
retraite qui sera rapporté par Madame
Félice Gérard groupe horizon et Monsieur
Charles de Courson groupe lot s'il n'y a
pas d'opposition je propose qu'il en
soit ainsi décidé pas d'opposition c'est
parfait par ailleurs pour la 6e mission
d'information la demande du groupe
Renaissance portant sur les dépenses
fiscales et budgétaires en faveur de
l'emploi et de la formation
professionnel qui sera rapporté par
Monsieur Dominique dailva groupe
Renaissance il convient que nous
disposions du nom d'un deuxième
rapporteur d'opposition avant de pouvoir
officiellement annoncer sa création il
est évident que ça devient assez urgent
pour pouvoir faire en sorte que cette
mission se mette en place donc ce que je
vous propose c'est que les cinq missions
déjà citées
commencent organisé par leur
corapporteurs à en place et évidemment
il est possible à partir de là de les
annoncer d'un point de vue de la
communication
merci passe maintenant donc à la partie
audition mes chers collègues je souhaite
la bienvenue à Monsieur Pierre
muscovicii qui vient nous présenter en
sa qualité de président du Conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires le rapport sur
le du conseil sur la fiscalité du
logement rendu publicque ce lundi 18
décembre c'est la deuxème occasion qui
nous est offerte cette année
d'auditionner le président du Conseil
des prélèvements oblig puisque nous
avions déjà entendu monsieur moscoviss
en mars sur le rapport du CPO relatif à
la taxe sur la valeur ajoutée c'est la
deuxème occasion de de l'auditionner à
ce titre hein parce que nous avons eu
tellement d'autres titres l'acquité des
questions de logement dans la période
actuelle est particulièrement forte et
nous avons déjà pu mesurer au cours de
l'automne l'importance des questions
fiscales portant sur secteur ce rapport
est d'autant plus bien venu il est
également particulièrement riche car à
côté du rapport général sont présentés
non seulement CIN rapports particul mais
également une évaluation de la réforme
de la taxe d'habitation menée par
l'institut des politiques publiques et
une étude des propriétés redistributives
de la taxe foncière sur les propriétés
bâties menées par l'INC monsieur le
Président du Conseil des prélèvements
obligatoires vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur général mesdames
et messieurs les députés je me réjouis
d'être à nouveau devant vous cette
fois-ci en effet en tant que président
du Conseil des prélèvements obligatoires
afin de vous présenter le rapport de ce
conseil intitulé pour une fiscalité du
logement plus cohérente je souhaite
avant tout saluer le travail de
l'ensemble des artisans de ce rapport
vous savez ce qu le Conseil des prél
obligatoire c'est une institution
associée à la Cour des comptes qui
réunit des élus locaux des magistrats
des fonctionnaires des universitaires
des représentants du monde de
l'entreprise à mes côtés se trouve le
vice-président du CPO Patrick lefard son
secrétaire général Guillem blondi que je
remercie
et je remercie également le rapporteur
général Vincent deudri qui a coordonné
une équipe d'une dizaine de rapporteurs
qui n'est plus aujourd'hui à la cour et
donc qui n'est pas avec nous ce matin le
rapport s'est nourrit de cette diversité
de points de vue ainsi que d'auditions
de parties prenantes des secteur du
logement social et de la construction
d'élus locaux d'économistes et de
représentants d'institutions
internationales il a bénéficier de deux
études inédites conduites pour lui
respectivement par l'INC sur la taxe
foncière et par l'Institut des
politiques publiques l'IPP sur la taxe
d'habitation avant de vous dévoiler les
principaux messages de ce rapport je
souhaiterais faire quelques rappels
rapides car vous connaissez ça aussi
bien que moi sur le secteur du logement
sur les défis structurels auquel il est
confronté sur la conjoncture à laquelle
il fait face le logement c'est un bien
particulier au cœur du quotidien des
citoyens comme de la vie économique du
pays en 2022 on comptait près de 38
millions de logements en France en
croissance de 320000 unités par rapport
à l'année précédente la dépense courante
des agents économiques pour le logement
en France s élevit à environ 581
milliards d'euros soit 22 % du PIB c'est
dire l'importance de ce secteur or le
logement est confronté aujourd'hui à
deux défis nouveaux qui doivent être
pris en compte par la fiscalité d'abord
je commence par là les enjeux
environnementaux pour atténuer les
effets du changement climatique pour
lutter contre l'artificialisation des
sols il est nécessaire de donner la
priorité à la mobilisation du parc
existant et la rénovation énergétique en
rupture avec les dispositifs fiscaux
existants qui favorisent eux
principalement la construction neuve
autrement dit dans notre rapport nous
avons intégré cette vision de la
transition environnmentale et
énergétique le second défi c'est la
concentration du patrimoine immobilier
chez les ménages les plus aisés et dans
les centres des grandes aires urbaines
ces question pose euh celle des effets
de la fiscalité du logement sur la
répartition des patrimoines au-delà de
ces nouveaux défis le marché de
l'immobilier nous le savons se
caractérise par un déséquilibre entre
l'offre et la demande de logement la
conjoncture économique actuelle marqué
par une hausse des taux d'intérêt et la
contraction corrélative très importante
des crédits
accentue les difficultés rencontrées par
les ménages et par le secteur de la
construction neuve le rapport du CP po
s'attache ainsi à proposer une révision
de la structure de la fiscalité du
logement pour répondre au défis de long
terme du bâti en maintenant globalement
à changer le niveau des prélements
obligatoires contenu de la situation des
finances publicques autrement dit nous
estimons qu'il est très difficile de les
augmenter continue du niveau des
prélatoires et très difficile de les
baisserue du niveau des
déficits disons-le tout de suite je veux
dire ce que rapport ce que ce rapport
n'est pas
il ne vise pas à proposer des remèes de
court terme aux difficultés rencontrées
en 2023 par le marché immobilier dont
nous savons qu'elle vont se prolonger
probablement en 2024 et peut-être
s'aggraver ce n'est pas un rapport de
conjoncture nos recommandations
permettrait néanmoins s'ils étaient mis
en œuvre d'après nous de rendre le
marché du logement plus résilient à
l'avenir face aux variations
conjoncturelle en réduisant l'IG prix
autrement dit ce n'est pas rapport de
conjoncture mais il peut protéger des
des effets de la conjoncture ces mesures
j'en viens à l'objet de notre rapport
c'estàd la fiscalité du logement là
aussi c'est un sujet non négligeable ça
représente au total 92 milliards d'euros
en 2022 prélevé tout au long du cycle de
vie du logement de sa construction à la
session les principaux impôts qui la
compos sont les droits de mutation
prélevés lors de l'acquisition d'un bien
par achat d'
héritage pour 28 milliards d'euros au
total et la taxe foncière qui frappe la
détention de biens immobiliers à hauteur
de 26 million milliards d'euros en
comparaison euh internationale la part
de la fisqué du logement dans le PIB en
France est parmi les plus élevés de
l'OCDE mais ceci relève plus du niveau
général des prél obligatoires d'entreps
que d'une structure de la fiscalité
défavorable au secteur le poids de ces
impôts dans le total des prélèvements
est ainsi plus important au Royaume-Uni
ou aux États-Unis qu'en France il est
également important de souligner que de
très nombreuses dépenses fiscales il y
en a 70 en 2022 viennent réduire le
rendement de la fiscalité du logement
elle représente une perte de recettes de
près de 15 milliards d'euros pour l'État
et les collectivité territorial le
rapport rappelle mais c'est une
préconisation plus générale de la cour
qu'elle a fait dans une note
structurelle paru l'an dernier que ces
dépenses fiscales comme toutes les
autres devrait être borné dans le temps
et systématiquement évalué nous avons
dans ce pays trop de dépenses fiscales
qui sont voté on sait pourquoi le jour
on les vote puis ensuite elle dure quasi
éternellement et on ne sait pas bien à
quoi elles servent au bout d'un moment
l'inventaire systématique des dépenses
fiscales devrait être fait certaines ont
des effets ambigus j'y reviendrai dans
la suite de cette présentation
j'aimerais conclure ce panorama
préliminaire en rappelant qui paye les
impôts sur le logement et qui les
perçoit depuis la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation sur les résidences
principales la fiscalité du logement
dépend du régime d'occupation et repose
de façon prédominante sur les
propriétaires elle est donc globalement
progressive puisque les locataires
notamment ceux du parc social sont dans
l'ensemble moins aisés que les
propriétaires est en revanche dégressive
en fonction du revenu parmi les
propriétaires autrement dit il vaut
mieux un locataire qu'un propriétaire il
vaut mieux être un propriétaire euh aisé
qu'un propriétaire pas aisé au regard de
la fiscalité du logement le poids de la
fiscalité du logement dans leur dépenses
de logement doit toutefis être
relativisé pour le quart des
propriétaires accédant les plus modestes
la fiscalité du logement représente
environ 6 % de le revenu c'est beaucoup
mais les ménages entrant dans cette
catégorie consacent plus de la moitié de
leur revenus à leur logement notamment
pour rembourser leur emprintt
immobiliers ce qui VE dire que en
réalité l'enjeu du crédit immobilier si
on veut réfléchir aussi à la crise
immobilière pèse bien davantage Queel de
la fiscalité en matière d'accès à la
propriété si on veut un moment donné
relancer cel c'est du côté du crédit va
falloir se pencher davantage que du côté
de la fiscalité je précise que
aujourd'hui nous parlons que de la
fiscalité puisque c'est Rapp du CPO par
rapport de la Cour par exemple malgré la
réforme de la TH les collectivités
locales restent bénéficiè de près de la
moitié des impôts et taxes sur le
logement pourra dire seulement la moitié
ou au moins la moitié comme on voudra ça
dépend de quel point de vue on se place
les communes reçoivent notamment la taxe
frontière et les départements les droit
de mutation à titre onéreux ou les DMTO
c'està-dire en langage courant les frais
de notaire se les achat bien de ce fait
la mise en œuvre de certaines des
recommandations de ce rapport
impliquerait des pertes de recettes pour
certaines collectivités et des gains
pour d'autres euh je voudrais préciser
que pour le CPO ces effets
redistributifs en collectivité devrait
être évidemment neutralisé c'est quelque
chose qui que je veux dire de manière
très claire au début pour ne pas créer
d'ambigé il me semble important de
rappeler ces caractéristiques de la
fiscalité du logement avant de vous
présenter les trois principaux messages
de ce rapport 1 les dispositifs fiscaux
doivent selon nous être mis en cohérence
avec la valeur économique des biens
c'està-dire notamment le cas de la taxe
foncière dont l'assiette obsolète a des
effets
antiredistributifs 2 les aides
budgétaires ciblées sont le plus souvent
préférables aux incitations fiscales
pour faire face au nouveaux défi du bâti
en particulier dans la continuité du
précédent rapport du CPO nous
considérons je vous l'ai présenter que
le taux réduit de TVA je le redis
çaavait causé ici des débats je m'en
souviens le taux réduit de TVA n'est pas
un bon instrument pour favoriser des
rénovations énergétiques de qualité
enfin pour favoriser la résilience du
marché du logement il faut renforcer la
neutralité de la fiscalité sur ce
secteur en taxant la détention de biens
immobiliers de préférence à leur
acquisition ceci passe principalement
par une diminution des droits sur les
transactions qui pourra être compensé
par une hausse de la taxe foncière dès
lors que son assiette aurait été
modernisée ce qui renvoie au premier
point maintenant je vous présente
rapidement ces trois considérations
premier lieu donc nous pensons que les
dispositifs fiscaux doivent être mis en
cohérence avec la valeur économique des
biens une étude inédite que j'ai cité
réalisée par l'INC pour ce rapport
démontre que la taxe foncière présente
un profil régressif en fonction du
niveau de vie des propriétaires ceci
s'explique principalement par une
assiette archaïque qui sousévalue la
valeur de l'immobilier dans les communes
les plus aisées les coefficients ont été
déterminés en 19 170 pour caractériser
les biens il survalorise les
constructions neuves de cette époque qui
sont parfois dégradées aujourd'hui et
sous-évalue les immeubles anciens de
centr-eville aujourd'hui souvent très
côtés en outre les communes qui n'ont
pas d'activité économique importante sur
le territoire ont tendance à appliquer à
ces assiettes surestimées des taux plus
élevés que les communes les plus
dynamiques résultat le cumul de C de
effets fait que et c'est très visible à
Paris et dans la petite
couronne de nombreuxes immeubles de sa
sa qui étai neuf dans les années 70
souvent mieux équipé qu'à Paris ce qui
conduit à les imposer davantage au titre
des modes de calculassiette pour taxe
foncière alors que l'état du bâti a bien
entendu évalué ça conduit une taxe
foncière qui pèse de à tro fois plus
dans le revenu disponible en sa saint
qu'à Paris ce qui est quand même cont du
revenu qu'on connaît des habitants assez
abérrant
reconnaissonsle nous en déduisons que la
révision de l'assiette de la taxe
foncière est une réforme majeure et
nécessaire elle a malheureusement été
régulièrement repoussé au motif de
difficultés technique et de forts enjeux
redistributifs qu'elle présente selon le
gouvernement elle devrait intervenir
désormais en 2028 ces reports
consécutifs conduisent à une divergence
devenue considérable entre la fiscalité
foncière les capacités contributives des
ménages ces reports induisent également
un affaiblissement du consentement cet
impôt mais il laisse aussi du temps pour
réfléchir sur la méthodologie de cette
révision le CPO recommande de tirer
partie de l'amélioration des
statistiques disponibles sur les prix
des biens et les loyers pour fonder plus
directement la taxe foncière sur la
valeur locative de marché ou sur la
valeur vénale des logements ceci
permettrait à la taxe de refléter les
réalités économiques locales tout en
permettant pour l'avenir une
actualisation régulière et à moindre
coût pour l'actualisation pour
l'administration en dehors de la taxe
foncière les communes continuent de
percevoir la taxe d'habitation sur les
résidences secondaires et les logements
vacants tandis que les communes situées
en zone tendue peuvent aussi instituer
une taxe sur les logements vacants l'un
des objectifs de ces impôts est de
limiter le nombre de logements inoccupé
et de faciliter l'accès au logement dans
les zones tendues comme les grandes
villes ou les zones touristiques malgré
son actualisation en 2023 le zonage
défini au niveau national peine
cependant ici aussi à suivre les
dynamiques locales
du marché du logement le CPO propose
d'inverser la logique actuelle en
généralisant la taxe sur les logement
vacant sauf pour les territoires en
déprises cette mesure accroîrait l'offre
sur le marché locatif et limiterait la
consommation d'espace naturel pour des
constructions neuves elle simplifierait
en outre la fiscalité sur les logements
vacants puisqu'il n'y aurait plus de
taxe d'habitation pesant sur voilà pour
le premier message le second message sur
lequel je souhaite attirer votre
attention Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés concerne les nouveaux défis
auquels est exposé le bâti le rapport
relève que les incitations fiscales sont
rarement les meilleurs instruments pour
faire face au nouveaux défis auquels est
confronté le bâti c'est le cas des
incitations qui visent à atténuer les
effets de la conjoncture économique mais
aussi des incitations pour atteindre les
objectifs plus structurels sociaux
environnementaux de la politique de
logement c'estant de la conjoncture
économique qui nous intéresse tout de
même après des années de forte expansion
du seeur permise par l'auben de taux
historiquement bas la hausse des taux
s'est traduit par une baisse limitée des
prix en revanche elle a mené une hausse
très marquée des crédits accordés et des
transactions l'emploi dans le bâtiment
nous le savons résiste pour l'instant
mais pour combien de temps grâce à au
dynamisme des rénovations mais la baisse
des acquisitions et des constructions
neuves cré des tensions sur le marché
locatif cette situation rappelle le rôle
décisif pour le marché immobilier de
l'accès au crédit et de son coût et
l'incidence plutôt limitée de la
fiscalité que j'ai déjà évoqué c'est là
que réside le principal blocage
aujourd'hui l'utilisation de la
fiscalité à des fins de relance pour
favoriser l'accès à la propriété
pourrait même selon nous être
contre-productive en augmentant encore
les prix du logement l'étude commandé
par le CPO l'Institut des politiques
publiques l'IPP montre que la
suppression de taxe habitation sur le
résidence principale n'a pas
complètement échappé à cet écueil une
partie certes limitée du gain de pouvoir
d'achat été capté par une augmentation
du prix immobilier et des loyers cette
incidence contreproductive a été mise en
évidence de façon beaucoup plus nette
pour les aides à l'investissement
locatif la suppression du dispositif dit
borlau Robien en 2009 aurait ainsi
toutes choses égal par ailleurs conduit
à une baisse des prix de 1 % et une
réduction de la vacance de 1,6 % dans
dans les zones qui ne bénéficient plus
de ces dispositifs ceci conduit le CPO à
recommandé de ne pas prolonger le
dispositif d' Pinel qui présente des
caractéristiques analogues en matière
environnementale l'utilisation de la
fiscalité des fins incitativ doit être
sélective certains dispositifs fiscaux
pourra être mobilisés pour limiter
l'artificialisation des sols je pense
notamment à la taxe sur les plusvalu de
session des terrains n rendu
constructible la taxe sur les logements
vacants que j'ai déjà évoqué de même les
dispositifs de solvabilisation de la
demande comme les prêts à taux zéro
peuvent avoir un certain attrait dans un
contexte de hausse et taux d'intérêt il
devrait néanmoins être orienté selon
nous vers l'acquisition et la rénovation
de logements ancien qui permettent une
forme de sobriété foncière en revanche
et je le dis très clairement quit à
déplaire à certains recourir à l'outil
fiscal pour la rénovation énergétique ne
permet pas de répondre aux enjeux de
ciblage et d'efficience de cette
politique publique alors que de très
nombreux logements demeurent à rénover
d'ici 2050 notamment pour aider les plus
modestes à réduire le facture
énergétique le rapport démontre que les
taux réduits de TVA ne sont pas les
outils les plus efficients en effet ils
peuvent très difficilement être ciblés
et il ne concern d'ailleurs pas toujours
des logements
énergiv nous faisons donc sur ce sujet
le même type de proposition que nous av
fait sur la TVA en général lors de notre
dernier rapport
nous pensons qu'un alignement du taux
réduit de TVA de 55 pour les travaux de
rénovation énergétique sur les taux
intermédiaires de 10 % pour les travaux
de rénovation dans l'ancien pourrait
être recherché cela doit s'effectuer à
condition de redéployer le gain
budgétaire de ces réformes sur les aide
budgétaire directe c'est 1,9 milliards
c'est le chiffre que j'ai en tête par
ailleurs un tel alignement ne doit pas
empêcher de poursuivre un meilleur
ciblage de dispositifs budgétaires
notamment ma prime Renov
comme l'a rappelé un rapport de la Cour
des comptes réalisé pour la commission
d'évaluation et de contrôle de votre
assemblée rendu publ en octobre 2023 qui
est bien sûr à votre disposition 3è et
dernier message que je souhaitais porter
devant vous mesdames et messieurs les
députés contenu du bilan peu convaincant
de ces dispositifs fiscaux incitatifs le
CPO recommande de renforcer la
neutralité de la fiscalité afin de
favoriser la résilience du marché il
s'agit d'abord de chercher à taxer plus
la détention que l'acquisition c'est
davantage la rente immobilière que
l'effort d'accès à la propriété en
particulier les DMTO collectés par les
notaires pour les départements au moment
de l'acquisition d'un logement ont un
effet négatif sur le nombre de
transactions la mobilité résidentielle
et l'accès à la propriété le CPO réitère
une recommandation qu'il avait déjà
faite en 2018 de basculer
progressivement les droits de mutation à
titre onéreux vers la taxe foncière ce
transfert nécessiterait une réflexion
globale sur les circuits de financement
des collectivités qui permettrait de
fournir au Département des recettes plus
stables et moins lié au cycle
immobilier plusieurs d'entre vous sont
sans doute des élus départementaux il se
trouve que je circule un peu sur le
territoire pour rendre visite à nos
collec à nos chambres régional des
comptes j'étais à Rennes il y a 15 jours
à Dijon la semaine dernière et les
présidents de conseil généraux de ces
départements m'ont entretenu de la
baisse très importante conjoncturelle
des desmto aujourd'hui donc il y a
plutôt besoin de stabilité de ce côté-là
euh cependant cette réforme ne peut pas
être mise en œuvre tant que la fiscalité
foncière apparître rêlé des réalités
économiques locales donc je ne presse
pas pour le faire demain matin mais je
suggère de l'articuler avec ce que je
disais en première partie une telle
bascule ne doit pas être conçue comme
une mesure pour relancer les
transactions à court terme mais comme
une réforme de moyen terme donc après
2028 elle doit être couplée avec la
réforme de l'assiette de la taxe
poncière que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
ce que nous voulons ce que nous vous
proposons de viser c'est de renforcer la
flexibilité et la résilience du marché
de l'imolier de façon
durable nous pensons aussi qu'une plus
grande neutralité devrait être recherché
dans la taxation à l'impôt sur le revenu
des plusvalues immobilières le projet de
loi de finance pour
2024 procède à une première
rationnalisation du régime très
favorable des meublés de tourisme en
ramenant l'abattement dont il bénéficie
de 7 % à 30 % dans les zones tendues le
CPO invite à aller au-delà et à
supprimer progressivement la distinction
entre location meublée et non meublé la
distinction entre location meublée
professionnelle et non professionnelle
un régime microofoncier serait
applicable en dessous d'un de chiffre
d'affaires dans tous les cas mais le
niveau des abattements serait ramené à
30 ou 40 % et les règles de déduction et
d'amortissement de droit commun
s'appliquerait cette réforme permettrait
notamment de remettre sur le marché de
la location durable des biens réservés
aujourd'hui par le propriétaire à la
location touristique pour des raisons
d'optimisation fiscale notamment à Paris
et dans les communes touristiques voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs les trois messages
que je souhaitais porter à votre
attention renforcer la cohérence la
fiscalité du logement nécessite de la
reconnecter aux réalités économique
local de mettre en extinction les
dépenses fiscal inefficace ou
insuffisamment ciblé et de mieux
répartir l'imposition tout au long du
cycle de vie du logement à pression
fiscale constante une telle réforme est
très ambitieuse elle ne peut-être je le
sais que progressive il sera nécessaire
bien sûr de neutraliser ses effets sur
les finances locales mais aussi de
lisser dans le temps ses conséquences
pour les ménages il faut en effet
prendre en compte la situation légitime
de particulier ayant effectué un
investissement sous l'Empire ou sous
l'emprise d'un précédent régime fiscal
merci de votre attention et de votre
intérêt je suis à votre disposition
mesdames et messieurs les députés pour
répondre à à vos questions je précise
encore une fois au nom du Conseil des
prélement obligatoires qui est une
instituation collective et indépendante
rattaché ou associé à la Cour des
comptes merci monsieur le Président
quelques observations puis des questions
aussi première observation on est c'est
une audition extrêmement utile euh
puisque lors des dialogue de Bery euh
tout le monde s'était accordé pour
diagnostiquer euh que la question du
logement était une véritable bombe
sociale dans le pays
euh sur auquel il convenait évidemment
de
s'attaquer et je regrette d'ailleurs à
ce propos que contrairement à ma demande
dans les quelques missions que sur
lesquelles nous n'avons nous avons eu
l'occasion de de débattre en séance il
n'y ait pas eu la mission liée à la
question du logement alors même que
chacun considérait que c'était un des
thèmes essentiels y compris de la part
du gouvernement bon je veux croire
puisque ça a été annoncé au moment des
dialogues de verersi il y aura une
grande loi sur la question du logement
euh dans les mois à venir qui nous
permettra d'y revenir moi je avant de de
de de poser les questions sur la
fiscalité je vourrais dire il me semble
les les deux grands les grands deux
grands points sur lesquels cette
fiscalité agit c'està sur la situation
du logement la première c'est que le
logement est trop cher VO les prix du
logements sont trop chers je rappelle
que d'après la Fondation abépierre euh
la part des logement dans le budget des
ménages est passé de 20 % en moyenne en
90 à 27,8 % en moyenne aujourd'hui et
jusqu'à 45 % pour les ménages les plus
pauvres et une étude récente a actualisé
ses chiffres cette fois-ci d'xfam qui
explique que le premier poste de dépense
c'est 2 toujours logement est
aujourd'hui la premier poste de dépense
23 % du revenu brut contre 9,5 % 1960
quelques années après l'appel de la baé
piierre et que de très fortes disparités
se se voit puisque les 25 % des ménages
les plus modestes dépense 32 % de leur
revenus pour se loger contre 14,1 % pour
les 25 % les plus aisés et le prix de l'
immobilier lui entre 2001 et 2020 a
augmenté de 125,6 % alors que le revenu
disponible n'a progressé que de 29 %. on
voit donc la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes la deuxième point c'est que
il y a une baisse continue des dépenses
publiques pour le logement qui à mon
avis a un rapport aussi euh avec
cette hausse puisque en dernière instant
c'est c'est ces dépenses publiques qui
permettent à l'état d'intervenir sur la
question du marché du logement de 1,5 %
du PIB en 2010 nous sommes euh nous
sommes aujourd'hui à 1,5 % du PIB alors
qu'en 2010 on était à 2,2 % et que entre
2016 et 2021 on est passé de 42
milliards d'euros à 38 milliards d'euros
soit une baisse de 10,8 % et je rappelle
que la baisse de production de logements
sociaux évidemment suit cette baisse
dépenses publiqu puisquon on avait
126000 logements sociaux financés en
2016 96000 en 2022 et que d'après les
chiffres donnés par les fédérations des
logements sociaux il en aura à peu près
82000 cette année soit le plus bas
chiffre depuis 2005 voilà à mon avis les
éléments qu'on doit avoir en tête et
j'allais ajouter que quelque part la
hausse des taux d'intérêt finalement
bloque définitivement le système puisque
les classes intermédiaires se retrouvent
aujourd'hui avec des difficultés
d'acheter des logements neufs ce qui
d'ailleurs entre parenthèses provoque
aussi une crise dans le secteur du
logement maises deux questions c'est
sont celles-ci le rapport relève le
nombre élevé de dépenses fiscal en
faveur du logement 70 pour un coût
estimé à 15,5 milliards en 2022 soit un
6e du rendement de la fiscalité du
logement mais il évoque surtout la
difficulté de les évaluer la fragilité
des bases de données existantes sur le
logement notamment sur sa fisque qualité
le rapport évoque ainsi la suppression
du dispositif d' borlot Robia en 2009
qui aurait conduit à une baisse des prix
de 1 % et une réduction de la vacance de
1,6 % dans les zones ne bénéficiant plus
de ces dispositifs de même le coût élevé
les doutes sur l'efficacité du Pinel
sont mis en avant par le rapport enfin
un rapport publié par hxfam ce mois-ci
chiffre le coût de de tris de sénif
fiscal à près de 11 milliards d'euros en
12 ans et il n'est pas assuré que les
pertes de recettes qui auraient pu
financer 70000 logements sociaux soient
le meilleur levier de la politique du
logement donc compenu du coût et de la
durée des dispositifs fiscaux en faveur
de l'investissement locatif ne
faudrait-il pas inverser la logique
habituelle qui consiste à les évaluer
expost pour exiger au contraire une
évaluation exanté précise et exigeante
avant toute instauration par législateur
d'un nouveau dispositif fiscal en faveur
de l'investissement locatif deème
question votre rapport confirme un
constat qui était déjà bien établi la
déconnexion des valeurs locatives
cadastrales de la valeur de marché qui
conduit à sous-évaluer la valeur
l'immobilier dans les communes les plus
aisés et donc a un taux d'imposition des
logements qui décroit fortement avec
leur valeur de marché vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure il rappelle vous
rappelez votre rapport rappelle que la
SC S a des logements dont la valeur
locative cadastrale est en moyenne
supérieure à celle des logements de
Paris le rapport souligne également que
la révision qui doit intervenir
prochainement ne semble je cite ne
semble pas pouvoir assurer la cohérence
fine de l'assiette de la fiscalité du
logement avec la valeur économique des
biens vous suggérez de s'orienter vers
une taxation la valeur vénale pour mieux
refléter la valeur du marché pourtant
cette modalité a été exclue par la DG
FIP qui a opposé des obstacles
techniques dès lors que la révision des
valeurs locatives cadastrales qui
devrait à l'origine intervenir en 2026 a
été reporté à 2028 ne faudrait-il pas
saisir de ce temps supplémentaire pour
penser mettre en œuvre une réforme en
profondeur plutôt qu'un simple
ajustement voilà mes deux questions et
je passe la parole au rapporteur
général merci Monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Président la Cour
des comptes merci beaucoup pour votre
exposé de deux trois petits éléments
d'abord vous dites
et je suis assez content de l'entendre
que les dispositifs fiscaux euh n'ont
pas toujours les effets euh compense et
c'est vrai que nous avons quelque foois
nous tendance à essayer de régler tous
nos problèmes avec de nouveaux
dispositifs fiscaux et vous donner deux
exemples à la fois le invvestissement
fiscaux sur l'investissement locatif qui
sont contre-productifs puisqu'ils
amènent une augmentation euh de de
l'immobilier et et aliment euh la
spéculation et le deuxième que vous
donnez c'est donc sur la rénovation où
le taux réduit ne vous semble pas
apporter les effets les effet escompté
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent que
le marché de l'immobilier doit s'ajuster
aujourd'hui qu'il nous faut éviter
deavoir trop de dispositifs de soutien
trop tôt autrement on va alimenter les
prix pr extrêmement élevé peut-être
aussi
préciser pas parlé directement mais
c'est que par que c'est une contrevérité
que j'entends beaucoup c'est que les
contraintes qui pèsent sur les logements
de type qui ont le DPE G sont sont
aujourd'hui non pas des biens qui sont
immobilisés au sens où il sortirai du
marché au contraire c'est le marché le
plus dynamique aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
que cette contrainte que nous avons en
matière de transformation énergétique
amène des mouvements très importants sur
ce type de de logement soit parce que
les gens on pas la volonté de faire
euxmême la rénovation soit parce que il
voit bien que un logement qui est une
passoire thermique va à
terme valoir moins qu'un logement qui
lui atteint ses objectifs en matière de
transition écologique j'ai quatre
questions monsieur le Président la
première touche les les les DMTO
effectivement et bascule des DMTO vers
la taxes
foncière on envoie l'intérêt pour les
collectivités territoriales vous l'avez
dit on envoie l'intérêt pour la fluidité
du marché mais ça fait peser quand même
une augmentation extrêmement
significative des DMTO de l'ordre de 60
% en grande de l'ordre de 60 % en grande
masse et et un report de
effectivement ceux qui font
l'acquisition vers ceux qui sont déjà
propriétaires ce sont pas les mêmes qui
vont porter cet effort donc cet effort
me paraît quand même très important je
ne sais pas comment on pourrait le
justifier même en en lissant les effets
sur une période période très longue
deuxième question ça touche les valeurs
locatives on est tous d'accord sur le
constat et merci encore pour les travaux
les éléments très précis que vous nous
donnez mais pourquoi on y arrive pas
quoi est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il faut
vraiment faire pour enclencher ça parce
que c'est vrai que ça évidemment il y a
beaucoup de beaucoup de gagnants et
beaucoup et beaucoup de perdants et donc
on sait bien que ce type de réformes il
sont pas faciles à prendre et et et à
assumer
politiquement sur le régime de de
plus-value immobilière vous êtes passé
rapidement c'est un débat que nous avons
eu en de très nombreuses reprises ici il
s'agit d'un point important de la
fiscalité du logement qui représente des
recettes importants et ce qui suppose de
trouver un équilibre entre lutte contre
la rétention foncière immobilière et
lutte contre la spéculation au regard de
ces impératifs pourriz-vous nous revenir
sur la réforme préconisé par votre
rapport qui invite à tenir compte de
l'érosion monétaire et des travaux
d'amélioration des logements plutôt que
de leur durée de détention je c'est un
élément qui plaira au président
matthi sur le taux réduit de TVA sur la
rénovation énergétique vous nous dites
que ça n'est pas efficace pourriez-vous
comment comment avez-vous êtes-vous
arrivé à ces à ces à ces conclusion et
puis dernière question sur l'IFI vous
sous-entendez que ce disp positif est
peu contrôlé
aujourd'hui est-ce que il y a pas assez
de contrôle fiscaux est-ce que est-ce
que il y a voilà quels sont les biaiss
aujourd'hui qui ne qui vous font dire
que cette imposition n'est pas assez
contrôlée je vous remercie merci
monsieur le Président je vous propose de
répondre à ces premières
questions merci Monsieur le le président
bon sur les sur les dépenses fiscales
euh vous vous m'interrogez sur le point
de savoir s'il faut uneation expost ou
exanté je vois pas de contradiction
entre les deux ce que je constate
d'abord c'est que nous avons des facto
70 dépenses fiscales dont certaines sont
quand même importantes réduction
d'impôts en faveur de l'investissement
locatif c'est lié du flot Pinel c'est
1ard852 déductibilité aère des
charargesation c'est 1illard 650 TVA 10
% sur les dépenses d'amélioration et
gros entretiens c'est 4 millard3 euh et
cetera TVA 55 sur les travaux de
énergétiqu c'est 1900 c'est 1ard 980
chiffre que je vous donnais tout à
l'heure donc c'est sont des choses assez
considérables qui ont été créé
historiquement il y a quelques temps et
dont nous pensons que si on veut les
repenser il faut d'abord en effet les
évaluer et il faut les plafonner dans la
durée ça c'est une recommandation
générale et donc l'évaluation expost est
nécessaire si vous voulez revenir sur
des dépenses fiscal existant
si on veut en créer une nouvelle euh
effectivement à ce momentlà l'évoluation
aveanté me paraît sans doute une
approche nécessaire et et intelligente
est-ce qu'on peut euh vraiment réformer
les valeurs cadastrales en tout cas ce
que nous pensons c'est que il est in
contontestable que cette réforme est
aussi nécessaire que complexe tant pour
des raisons d'acceptabilité par les
citoyens que pour des raisons
administratives c'est pas spécifique à
la France puisque une réforme de cette
nature a été également reportée en euh
Allemagne euh c'est pas impossible comme
le prouve la révision des valeurs
locatives des locaux professionnels et
donc l'aboutissement de cette réforme
nécessite deux conditions préalables
détaillées par le CPO d'abord elle
pourra être aménagée comme ça a été le
cas pour les locaux professionnel pour
garantir son acabilité sociale et nous
pensons aussi qu'il faut étaler les
effets de la réforme par exemple la
licence sur plusieurs années d'autre
part sur le plan technique il sera
possible à notre sens de s'appuyer sur
la de nouvelles techniques pour alléger
la charge administrative lié à cette
révision par exemple par le recours à
des modèles de valorisation automatisé
des biens immobiliers enfin nous pensons
qu'il ne faut pas fermer la porte à de
nouvelle modalité de réforme ainsi
l'option de la taxation à la valeur
vénale pourrait être envisagée sauf à ce
que les travaux techniques approfondi et
conduit à une trop grande volatilité une
chose est certaine en tout cas c'est que
plus cette réforme se fera tartivement
plus elle sera difficile voire
impossible j'en viens maintenant aux
question du rapporteur général
qui a évoqué la la rénovation
énergétique d'abord s'agissant de
l'interdiction progressive des passoir
thermique d'ici 2034 les effets sur les
prix du logement devront comme vous
l'avez dit être étudiés attentivement
mais ne sont pas encore établis et la
mesure peut être efficace pour
déclencher l'acte de rénovation sous
réserve que les propriétaires soient
accompagnés techniquement et
financièrement je reviens maintenant à à
vos questions sur la des des MTO
personne ne dit que ce soit une mesure
complexe c'est némoins la proposition du
du
CPO je rappellerai d'abord que cette
réformme s'effectu à niveau de
prélèement obligatoire constant qu'elle
doit être neutre pour les
collectivitésoriales c'est un point
évidemment important sur le fond de
votre question cette réforme aura
mécaniquement pour effet de faciliter
les transactions immobilières en
fludifiant le marché elle bénéficiera
donc effectivement principalement au
ménag accédent et qu'elle favorisera
l'accession de mage pas aujourd'hui les
man d'acheter donc très clairement le
parti prix ou la logique du CPO c'est
effectivement de favoriser l'acquisition
par rapport à la rente et donc par
rapport à la détention l'ampleur et la
nature des effsustritif dépendront
cependant également d'autres variables
en particulier les taux de crédit
immobilier en ce qui concerne les effets
redistributifs entre contribuables
l'idée portée par le rapport est Procé
d'abord à la révision de l'assiet de la
taxe foncière avant d'engager la bascule
donc profiter du mouvement qui va vers
2028 pour préparer cette bascule dans
tous ces aspects euh puisque le le le la
l'assiette de la taxe frontière Est de
la vie de tous obsolète ça ne sera pas
en un jour ça nécessitera de compenser
son impact pour les collectivités mais
aussi lisser ces effets pour les
contribables afin d'éviter tout effet
redistributif trop abrupte au regarde
des études mené par l'INC cette première
phase bénéficiera principalement
contribu à des zones périurbaines des
grandes agglomérations
et aux habitants des espaces peu denses
la Meuse lesvoges la Creuse l'AUE
l'garon par exemple qui ont aujourd'hui
un taux d'imposition de logement très
élevés en lien avec des bases obsolètes
donc nous pensons que cette réforme est
possible n sousestimons pas la
difficulté mais je je ne tirerai pas un
trait dessus au contraire puisque je
suis là pour la présenter est-ce qu'on
peut vraiment réformer les les VLC je
crois avoir répondu à cette question euh
sur les plus-values immobilières euh
dans la continuité en effet du rapport
de Monsieur matiller monsieur sensu de
septembre 2023 le CPO propose de
remplacer les abattements pour durée de
détention par une prise en compte plus
progressive de l'érosion monétaire nous
y ajoutons la prise en compte des
travaux d'amélioration réalisés par le
vendeur l'objectif c'est d'éviter là
aussi les comportements de rétention
foncière que favorise le système actuel
tout en encourageant la rénovation
notamment énergétique de logement avant
leur vente une telle réforme modifie
évidemment assez sensiblement le
rendement d'un investissement immobilier
elle devrait donc être mise en œuvre
progressivement avec une clause de
grand-père pour les investisseurs qui
ont acquis leur bien avant son entrée en
vigueur j'en viens enfin faisons
prolonger votre rapport monsieur le
député j'en viens auutau réduit de TVA
55 pour les
particuliers disons que selon nous
l'existence de deux taux de réduit de
TVA sur les travaux pour logement pose
question d'abord il est quand même pas
toujours facile de faire la distinction
ou la différence entre ce qui est de la
rénovation énergétique le taux à 55 et
ce qui est la simple amélioration le
taux à 10 par ailleurs il y a toujours
le risque que les entreprises du
bâtiment aillent à la simplicité en
inscrivant pour toutes les actions le
tau à 55 ce qui représenterait un manque
à gagner supplémentaire pour l'État on
peut rappeler également que ces taux ne
sont pas si ciblé sur certains ménages
ou sur certains travaux les ménages
aisés ont recours au T à 55 y compris
pour des rénovations très
partielles ce qui n'est pas une
utilisation efficace des donniers
publics c'est pas ceux qui ont besoin de
cette sorte d'auben c'est pour ces
différentes raisons que le CPO
recommande de supprimer le tau à 55 de
l'aligner sur le tau à 10 % il y aura
aussi de cette sorte un taux
amélioration rénovation à 10 % beaucoup
plus simple beaucoup plus plus lisible
ce serait aussi un moyen de lutter
contre la fraude on pourrait par
cohérence en exclure des travaux qui
sont préjudiciables à l'environnement
comme la mise en place de chaudiè avec
de l'énergie carbonée le gain pour les
finances publiques serait significatif
d'au moins donc 1,9 milliards d'euros
peut-être plus il serait rebasculé
d'après nous sur les aides budgétaires à
la rénovation énergétique comme un prime
renove et ce serait quand même une
augmentation peut-être importante mais
enfin ça c'est l'étape d'après en
quelque sorte euh sur la suppression des
DMTO et le relèvement du concurrence de
la TFP j'ai aussi répondu à cela sur
l'IFI sur l'IFI nous n'avons pas
vraiment traité le sujet voilà pourquoi
je nous l'avons évoqué évoqué mais pas
pas davantage nous y reviendrons merci
on va passer aux orateurs de groupe on
va commencer par Dominique Da Silva pour
renaissance pour 2 minutes oui merci
monur monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président je salue le le travail du
Conseil des prélèvements obligatoires
car il nous faut c'est certain nous doté
d'une fiscalité du logement plus
cohérente et cette
cohérence devrait d'abord nous
interroger sur les hauts niveaux à la
fois de prélèvement et d'aide concernant
le logement car la France est doublement
championne de l'Union européenne en la
matière c'est donc une lourde fiscalité
qui repose beaucoup sur les
propriétaires et aussi des aides
nombreuses qui Infiné profite davantage
aux acteurs concernés qu'au ménag qui
peinent à se loger malgré vous l'avez
dit 92 milliards d'argent public prélevé
deux orientations du rapport me semblent
aller dans le bon sens comme préférer
des aides CIBL ciblé pardon plutôt que
des incitations fiscales et mettre en
cohérence les dispositifs fiscaux avec
la valeur économique des logement en
revanche comme le rapporteur général je
suis très réservé sur la recommandation
qui consiste à faire transfert de la
fiscalité de l'acquisition vers la
détention de du logement je vois bien
l'idée poursuivie de faire baisser le
prix de l'immobilier en particulier pour
les primau accédents mais on ne résoudra
pas le problème si en échange d'une
baisse des droits de mutation on
augmente très fortement la taxe foncière
c'est même je dirais anachronique car en
10 ans les propriétaires ont payé en
moyenne plus de 26 % de taxes foncière
d'après l'UNPI et rien qu'en 2023 la
taxe foncière a progressé en moyenne de
9 % on a tous en mémoire les plus 60 %
de Paris à Paris pardon c'est
sincèrement une fausse bonne idée car on
découragera les Français à devenir
propriétaires si on baisse une taxation
des DMTO unique et prévisible assis sur
un prix d'achat négociable par une
hausse de la taxe froncière
nécessairement croissante et
imprévisible à vie monsieur le Président
pensez-vous qu'un propriétaire doit être
davantage taxé qu'un locataire même si
de toute évidence il aura subir une
hausse de son loyer en
conséquence merci Philippe lotio pour le
RN non monsieur
de allez-y merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur général monsieur
le Président du Conseil mes chers
collègues les conclusions du rapport du
Conseil des prélèvements obligatoires
évoquent l'épineuse question de la part
réduite des recettes fiscales liées au
logement qui revient aux collectivités
territoriale la réduction des ressources
locales engendre une réduction des
services à la population et constitue un
frein au politique de production et de
rénovation des logements après avoir
supprimé la taxe d'habitation puis la
cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprise le gouvernement remet en
cause la taxe foncière par différentes
exonérations quand elle représentait la
dernière source de fiscalité locale
dynamique pour les communes le projet de
loi finance pour 2024 prvoit que les
travaux de rénovation lourde des
logements sociaux dans le parc ancien
ouvriront le droit à de nouvelles
exonérations de taxes foncières de
longue durée le projet de loi de finance
pour 2024 transforme par ailleurs un
crédit d'impôt national le crédit
d'impôt pour la transition énergétique
en un crédit d'impôt local ouvrant la
possibilité aux propriétaires de
disposer de nouvelles exonérations de
taxes foncières de courte durée l'objet
du présent rapport étant de proposer au
gouvernement une fiscalité du logement
plus cohérente pourquoi n'avoir pas
développé une réflexion sur cette
question pourtant cardinale l'État ne
peut pas continuer de financer sa
politique du logement avec l'argent des
collectivités
territoriales merci Sébastien r pourfi
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
cette
présentation de de ce rapport du du du
Conseil des prélèvements obligatoires je
rappellerai que le logement c'est c'est
un bien premier d'abord essentiel pour
construire sa vie c'est un facteur
d'aménagement du du territoire de du
lien social on pense à à la mixité
notamment c'est un droit opposable aussi
qui existe et c'est un facteur culturel
dans dans nos villes donc tout un tas de
fonctions qui sont hors du marché et qui
impliquent que
l'intervention publique l'intervention
fiscale doit aller au au-delà en fait de
la concentration de la spéculation de la
déconnexion des prix de l'immobilier de
l'inflation et des revenus tel qu'on le
voit aujourd'hui alors nos propositions
ont souvent été repoussées ont toujours
été repoussées comme le le blocage des
loyers l'augmentation des de la taxe sur
le logement vacant la réquisition des
logements vacants mais je reviendrai
avec trois questions ne faut-il pas
introduire des barêes aussi sur le
revenu et ou sur les les types de de
contribua que ce soit les sociétés les
propriétaires occupant les propriétaires
d'un seul logement ou de plusieurs
logements ce qui permettrait aussi de de
mettre un peu de justice fiscale dans le
le logement le secteur du logement c'est
le c'est le secteur qui a le plus
d'impact du point de vue écologique ne
faudrait-il pas aussi remettre en cause
la question de la neutralité fiscale du
logement que vous avez présenté
aujourd'hui en allant chercher d'autres
secteurs qui contribuent par exemple
ceux qui contribuent à à augmenter le
nombre de déplacements sur sur les
territoires ou avec un un nouveau ISF
peut-être aussi et enfin ne faudrait-il
pas je vais utiliser un gros mot
socialiser une partie du foncier avec
des systèmes de de foncière et de
démembrement pour éviter que l'argent
public ne soit capté en fait par
quelquesuns et que la valeur foncière
reste dans le domaine public merci merci
Émilie benivard pour les républiquain
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le le le président plusieurs
questions vous n'avez pas eu d'approche
des différences de de fiscalité ça
aurait été intéressant je pense entre la
fiscalité mobilière et immobilière qui a
aussi pu déséquilibrer le le marché
pouvez-nous vous nous en dire un
[Musique]
mot vous parlez dans votre rapport de
dispositifs fiscaux spécifiques visant
la rénovation dans d'autres pays est-ce
que vous pouvez nous donner des
exemples trè point
je voudrais savoir qui a eu cette riche
idée d'imaginer la suppression des DMTO
pour augment en augmentant la taxe
foncière je crois vraiment que ce ce ce
sont des idées dont dont il faut se
passer euh très
honnêtement puisque une augmentation de
la taxe foncière c'est vraiment le lapin
dans le sac pour le nouveau
propriétaire j'aimerais savoir à quel
moment et bien la collectivité serait
bénéficiaire puisque sur la DMTO elle
est bénéficiaire une fois sur la taxe
foncière évidemment c'est sur le long
terme et évidemment cela se traduirait
par une augmentation forcément des
loyers pour les locataires donc
réellement très mauvaise idée
d'augmentation de la taxe foncière
j'aurais souhaité savoir si vous pouviez
ou si vous aviez pu faire une évaluation
de l'augmentation de la taxe foncière en
France depuis la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation moi je me demande comment N
citoyens de classe moyenne arrivent à
payer leur taxes fontière aujourd'hui
alors merci de ne pas augmenter et enfin
c'est une question sur les meublés de
tourisme on a une structuration de
l'hébergement touristique notamment en
montagne mais dans certaines zones
touristiques qui est basée sur les
meublés tourisme et les résidences
secondaires c'est le cœur du réacteur de
notre économie touristique si nous
baissons drastiquement les abattements
fiscaux sur ces meublés là comment
éviter la sortie de ces du marché
locatif et donc et bien l'rition de
notre économie touristique je parle des
zones touristiques qui ne sont pas
forcément des zone tendu je vous
remercie merci Mohamed Laquila pour le
groupe démocrate merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président ce
rapport arrive donc à point nommé pour
nous permettre d'engager des mesures
efficaces pour rénover cette fiscalité
et contribuer Enfin résoudre la crise du
logement j'aurais au nom de mon groupe
quelques questions pour mieux
appréhender les conclusions du rapport
que vous n présentez aujourd'hui la
première question dans le cadre du PLF
de 2024 le Gouvernement a souhaité
recentrer le prê à zé dans les zones
tendues au sein d'habitat collectif pour
le neuf ainsi il sera plus possible de
disposer du PTZ pour un logement neuf
dans les zones détendues à la lumière de
vos travaux auriez-vous des éléments sur
les conséquences que pourrait avoir
cette mesure sur l'offre de logement en
France la deuxème question pourriez-vous
tout d' d'abord nous expliquer en quoi
la révision des valeurs locatives
cadastrales peut encourager la
construction de nouveaux logements et
stimuler l'investissement
immobilier 3è question nous vous
rejoignons au groupe démocrate dans le
constat que les abattements pour durée
de détention conduisent à dincités à la
circulation du capital immobilier nous
avons porté dans le cadre du PLF une
réforme similaire à l'une de vos
recommandations à savoir remplacer ce
système par une prise en compte de
l'érosion monétaire tout en imposant les
plus-values à la flactaxe dans votre
proposition vous souhaitez aussi que la
taxe forfaitaire soit réhaussée pour les
terrains nus rendus constructible quelle
réflexion vous a conduit à inclure cet
élément dans le dispositif par ailleurs
avez-vous évalué l'impact financier
qu'aurait la mise en place de la mesure
que vous proposez sur nos finances
publiques est-il enfin judicieux de
mettre en place cette réforme prog ement
pour ne pas déstabiliser le marché merci
merci Christine PZ B pour groupe
socialiste ah bon ben j'ai pas compris
alors ah d'accord je crois que vous
aviez inversé
et bien merci monsieur le Président
chers collègues merci de m'accueillir à
nouveau dans votre commission monsieur
le Premier Président le Conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires a produit et
je tiens à le saluer au nom de mon
groupe une série de documents très
riches attendu et qui qui manqueront pas
d'animer nos débats dans les mois à
venir je souhaite en particulier attardé
dans le rapport particulier numéro 2 sur
la fiscalité des revenus locatifs dont
vous dénoncez comme nous l'effet de
distorsion en faveur des meublés de
courte durée au détriment de la longue
durée et de l'achat les parties 2.3.4 et
2.3.5 du rapport sont même si proches de
ce que nous disons depuis des mois avec
ma collègue anï glemer qu'on pourrait
croire qu'il s'agit d'un extrait du
rapport sur notre propre proposition de
loi visant à réduire les déséquilibre du
marché locatif dont l'examen s'achèvera
le 29 janvier vous proposez comme nous
de supprimer l'abattement fiscal de 71 %
dont vous précisez qu'il n'est plus
justifié et d'abaisser le plafond de
déductibilité la version du rapporteur
général de l'article 5 du haut des sièes
du PLF a ainsi bien fait d'être écarté
par le 493 cependant vous ne
réinterrogez pas le plafond de 77700 €
tout en soulignant la nécessité de
réduire l'écart de rentabilité entre la
location nu dont le plafond n'est qu'à
15000 € et la location meublée dans
l'optique d'un alignement souhaitable
des plafonds à quel niveau pensez-vous
que celui-ci devrait se situer vous
proposez également d'un unifier les
régimes fiscaux de la location meublée
et la location nu autour du régime
foncier dont nous partageons l'intention
mais j'aimerais que vous développiez
votre vision des amortissement dans ce
nouveau régime en effet si nous avons
déjà engagé la logique de suppression de
la double déductibilité de ces
amortissements la question de l'assiette
de celle-ci et des modalités de
réintégration de ces montants au moment
de la session est posée pouvez-vous
préciser le dispositif de réforme que
vous proposez dans le tableau 11 du
rapport comment jugez-vous à cet égard
les dispositions de l'article 3 de la
proposition que je porte avec an glemer
et le président casbarian pensez-vous
que la location nu de longue durée
devrait bénéficier d'un régime plus
favorable ou encore que des exceptions
devraient être conservées pour les
communes concernées par la problématique
des l froids enfin alors que vous
évoquez dans votre rapport la difficulté
à mener une politique fiscale dans la
finesse de la diversité des marchés
locatifs locaux que pensez-vous du
renforcement de la boîte à outil fiscal
à la main des maires thrrs TLV je vous
remerci merci François gelivet pour le
groupe horizon merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur monur le premier
président merci d'avoir rappelé que le
poids du logement représentait 22 % du
PIB soit 581 milliards d'euros vous
précisez que les deux défis nouveaux
sont concernent les enjeux
environnementaux et et et la
concentration du patrimoine qui est
observé je voudrais d'abord réagir à
cela c'est que réviser la fiscalité de
notre pays c'est d'abord doit être
gouverné par les objectifs alors je
comprends bien ces deux objectifs mais
je ne vous ai pas entendu parler
simplement de satisfaire au besoin des
demandeurs de logement ou par ailleurs
de veiller à la mixité sociale sur le
territoire la fiscalité n'étant qu'un
moyen et c'est souvent parce que la
fonction support qu'on appelle
financement le dessus que les ministères
métiers s'affaent dans notre pays ma
première question concerne votre idée de
réviser les valeurs locatives alors ce
n'est pas un événement c pas un fait
nouveau une volonté nouvelle puisque la
cour et le Conseil avaient déjà ouvert
cette possibilité le gouvernement en
tous les cas à réfléchir sur ce sujet et
d'ailleurs les collec activités local
ont déjà la possibilité de le faire mais
sans doute ne le font-elles pas par
manque de courage et parfois par paresse
et la paresse pouvant s'observit avec
une augmentation simplement de 50 % de
taux taxonciè par exemple comme à Paris
et je voudrais simplement réagir au fait
que l'alignement des valeurs locatives
de l'assiette sur la valeur véritable
des biens pourrait bien amener encore
des gens plus pauvres à quitter et à
éloigné par exemple en région parisienne
le territoire o ils ont acheté il y a 40
ans parce qu'une ou de métro serait
arrivé sans qu'il l'IT vraiment décidé
même si ça porte un service et en fait
ces gens-là seraient amené à quitter
leur territoire et nous aurions comme
effet un effet de concentration de
ghetto à riche et ça je trouve ça très
anormal donc je voudrais savoir comment
vous
pouvez avez-vous imaginé une mécanique
qui permet d'atténuer ces conséquences
dont tout le monde parle d'ailleurs
ensuite je voudrais vous dire combien
nous sommes d'accord dans le groupe
horizon apparenté pour la suppression
des des niches fiscales et notamment du
Pinel même si de manière très très
paradoxale le Pinel a permis au
collectivité locale d'éviter d'investir
dans le logement social puisque dans les
opérations mixtes cela permettait de de
valider la vente à perte du patrimoine
construit aux organismes HLM et
d'équilibrer l'opération avec une niche
fiscale dont l'état devait supporter les
conséquences enfin je voudrais réagir
par par rapport aux propos des de mon
collègue socialiste concant la taxation
des locations de court terme location de
cour terme le mot location je parler
plutôt de facturation et pourquoi n'avez
pas vous envisager la TVA et de facturer
simplementes ces occupations temporaires
d'un patrimoine merci pour le groupe
écologiste éteindre votre micro merci
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur
Moscovici pour cette présentation nous
partageons l'objectif du rapport du
Conseil des prélèvements obligatoire que
vous nous avez présenté à savoir adapter
la fiscalité du logement aux enjeux
actuels du bâti en France la transition
écologique la justice sociale et la
réduction des inégalités patrimoniales
sur le premier enjeu celui de la
transition écologique votre proposition
de relever le taux de TVA sur la
rénovation thermique à 10 % nous paraît
néanmoins particulièrement
contre-productive au moment où le nombre
de rénovation stagne et reste très
insuffisant pour répondre aux enjeux
climat sur ce sujet une des prop de la
FFB et de mettre en place un dégrèvement
des DMTO sur l'acquisition des biens
classés F ou G pour permettre aux
acquéreurs de financer la rénovation des
passeoirs thermiques j'aurais aimé avoir
votre avis sur cette proposition qui
nous paraît intéressante concernant
l'artificialisation des sols l'extension
de la taxe sur les logements vacants est
nécessaire pour répondre à la demande de
logement tout en maîtrisant
l'artificialisation des terres à ce
titre à compté du 1er janvier 2024 près
de
3690 communes vont être concerné par le
décret du 26 août 2023 étendant la liste
des communes pouvant instaurer la taxe
annuelle sur les logement vacant et une
majoration de la THRs cette mesure vous
paraît-elle suffisante au regard de ces
enjeux et enfin dernier point je dois
dire que nous restons un peu sur notre
fin à la lecture de ce rapport les
évolutions de la fiscalité que vous nous
proposez ne nous paraissent pas répondre
à la crise du logement qui que nous
connaissons actuellement selon la
Fondation abpier 4,1 millions de
personnes sont mal logées habitant dans
des appart exigu ou suroccupé hébergé
par des tiers ou même à la rue comme
c'est le cas de plus de 3000 personnes à
Paris pouvez-vous donc éclairer la
représentation nationale sur les
évolutions de la fiscalité du logement
qui pourrait contribuer à répondre à
cette grave crise du logement en France
je vous remerci bien et si je me suis
pas trompé dans les échanges gestuels
c'est Charles de courourson qui
intervient voilà Michel Castellan après
ou qure questions voilà vous proposez
d'étendre à de nouvelles communes la TLV
mais d'après vos études quelle est
l'efficacité actuelle de la TLV qui
était que ces logements en vacan soi
loué ou vendu 2è question passer de 55 à
10 % de taux de TVA sur la rénovation
énergétique est-ce que c'est vraiment
une bonne idée 3è question que
pensez-vous de la règle de non
répercussion de la taxe foncière sur le
locataire d'un logement alors que cette
même taxe foncière est répercutable sur
d'un bien
professionnel et puis dernière question
dans votre constat numéro 15 vous
montrez que les logements en
EFG en fait leur proportion n'est pas
très différente selon le niveau de
revenu puisque si on prend E + F+ G on
est à 38 39 % ça va de 41% pour le Q1 à
37% pour le Q5 alors qu'est-ce que vous
préconisez et qu'est-ce que vous voulez
dire quand vous évoquez une politique
visant à lever les obstacles à la
rénovation énergétique mais quels sont
les obstacles qu'il faut
lever merci je vous propose de répondre
à ces questions et comme on a pas mal de
réponses supplémentaires on les fera de
questions supplémentaires on les fera
après merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je vais essayer de
répondre aux questions en précision que
je ne vais pas reprendre les éléments
que j'ai déjà développé euh ou des
réponses que j'ai déjà faites et en
disant un petit peu quand même ce qu'est
le CPO vous me demandiez qui a eu cette
idée sous
grrenu le CPO le conseil préogatoire
c'est un une institution indépendante
pluraliste qui regroupe je l'ai dit des
élus pluralistes également plusieurs
tendances des acteurs économiques des
universitaires des fonctionnaires des
magistrats de la Cour des comptes tout
de même avec une dizaine de rapporteurs
qui par ailleurs font le rapport en
consultant très largement donc c'est un
travail collectif et c'est la
proposition du CPO et elle est arrêtée
de manière extrêmement consensuel Infiné
il y a pas de rapport qui ne sorte du
CPO qui nait pas été adopté par tous ces
membres c'est aussi simple que ça et
deuxième chose que je précise dans vos
questions il y a des remarques qui ne
sont pas des questions c'est naturel
vous êtes une assemblée nous nous sommes
là pour alimenter votre débat pas pour
le conclure ou pas pour ouvrir d'autres
sujets et donc je ne vais pas commenter
tel telle prise de position nous avons
fait une proposition elle est sur la
table on peut la réfuter ou l'accepter
voilà alors quand même une question qui
est transversale c'est est-ce que vous
voulez pénaliser plus les locataires que
les propriétaires c'était la première
question qui était posée je formulai
passe tout à fait les choses comme ça
mais je vous renvoie quand même au
tableau final de la conclusion du
rapport qui montre bien quel le système
actuel qui système pour lequel nous
voulons aller et en gros quand même nous
souhaitons que la détention soit
beaucoup plus taxée
qu'aujourd'hui que l'acquisition le soit
moins
euh que la rénovation le soit davantage
et et donc et que la location le soit un
tout petit peu plus donc effectivement
c'est c'est des fa distributif que nous
visons et auquel aboutirait notre
système je je ne peux pas le cacher nous
pensons en effet qu'il faut privilégier
plutôt l'acquisition que la détention et
plutôt la mobilité la rénovation que la
rente oui c'est la logique du rapport
après on peut estimer pas que la
proposition centrale qui est faite de
bascule est justifiée ou non mais je ne
saurais pas vous
mentir je je veux bien préciser que
c'est ça la
logique économique sociale politique
écologique qui soutend le rapport oui
c'est ça c'est sa philosophie on m'a
interrogé sur le fait de savoir pourquoi
ne pas avoir développé de réflexion sur
le financement de la politique de
logement par les collectivités tout
simplement parce que c'est un sujet qui
est pris en compte par le CPO d'abord
avec la nécessité de travailler
aprèslement constant car il ne faut pas
fragiliser les collectivités leur
financement et je redis aussi d'ailleurs
que les de bascules doivent être
strictement neutralisé bien sûr sur la
rénovation du du parc social et le
dispositif seconde vie c'est un défi
majeur pour lequel convient de trouver
des solutions de financement à long
terme d'après les estimations de l'Union
Sociale de l'habitat l'USH ça représente
environ 9 milliards d'euros pour 1500000
logements rénovés par an
réhabilité on peut nourrir toutefois
quelques doutes sur la pertinence du
dispositif de seconde vie qui prévoit
son financement par de nouvelles éations
de taxes foncière eu égard au coût que
ça représentera pour les communes
puisque ça vient s'ajouter à des
dégrèvements existants ou préexistants
autour de 25 % du coût des rénovations
et la Cour avait invité ça fait
longtemps déjà dès 2017 à remplacer ses
dégréments par des aides budgétaires
ciblées sur le logement social
l'hypothèse d'un élargissement du taux
de 55 à l'ensemble des opérations de
livraison logements sociaux neuf ne nous
apparaît pas opportune alors que le coût
des différents réduits taux réduit de
TVA sur ces opération dépasse 2
milliards d'euros en 2022 le CPO
démontre je crois l'absence de causalité
entre les modifications de ce taux qui
ont pu avoir lieu par le passé et
l'évolution du parc de logement sociaux
on peut relever en outre que les
difficultés liées à la hausse des taux
sont amoindr pour logement social par le
maintien du taux du livr à 3 % jusqu'en
janvier 2025 par ailleurs le secteur
bénéficie en 2023 d'un allègement de
cotisation la Caisse de garantie du
logement locatif social dont le coût
s'élève à 300 millions
d'euros la rénovation du parc social
c'est bien sûr un un défi majeur pour
lequel il faut trouver des solutions de
logement à moyen terme que je viens
d'évoquer à l'instant euh j'ai déjà
répondu aussi sur tout ce qui concernait
la bascule DMTO TFB en en disant aussi
que en effet cette bascule avait pour
effet de bénéficier principalement et
puisqu'on s'interroge sur les effs
redistributifs au contribua des zones
périurbaines des grandes agglomérations
et aux habitants des espaces peu dansse
que j'ai mentioné tout à l'heure ça
aussi c'est un une clarté que je veux
apporter euh sur l'idée de mettre les
revenus fonciers au barê de l'impôt sur
revenus le CPO propose d'aligner au sein
des revenus fonciers la location meublée
la location nue il nous paraît pas
souhaitable euh de les soumettre au
barem alors que euh les revenus des
capitaux sont soumis au pfu qui est plus
favorable que le taux applicable au
revenus fonciers nous n'avons pas traité
la question de la socialisation du
foncier parce que c'est pas dans notre
champ d'étude sur Location nu location
meublée
euh la différence d'imposition entre le
microbic et le microfoncier c'est une
particuli française en Europe euh seule
la Corée me dit-on pratique également
cette distinction nous sommes donc les
seul au monde avec la
Corée parce que ça encourage la location
meublée de courte durée ça réduit ainsi
le parc de logement disponible comme on
peut le constater dans les zones tendues
et de manière plus saisonnière dans les
communes touristiques et nous pensons
donc que cette réforme est nécessaire
pour faciliter la mobilité résidentielle
et pour encourager la location de plus
longue durée au profit des ménages les
plus modestes évidemment et ça vaut
d'ailleurs pour l'ensemble des propion
que nous faons je tiens à le dire c'est
transversal à toutes les questions que
vous avez posé cette réforme ne peut
aborder que de manière progressive dans
le temps pour éviter des effets de
redistribution trop abrupte c'est
pourquoi nous proposons de procéder
unification en deux étapes dans un
premier temps corriger les avantages
accordés au meublés de touristes par
rapport aux autres meublés rentrant dans
le régime microbique en ramenant
l'abattement de 71 à 50 % et en ramenant
le seuil à 77700 € et dans un second
temps après une étude d'impact ou une
évaluation prévoir une unification
complète des deux régimes avec un un
seuil ramené à 15000 € et un abattement
ramené à 30 % pour l'ensemble du régime
microfoncier le cas échéant la doossant
à une clause dite grandpère euh pour ce
qui est du PTZ Eco PTZ euh nous pensons
que la rationalisation territoriale du
PTZ est nécessaire au vu de sffet ambigu
vous savez qu'il conduit à à
d'importants effets d'ben d'après l'IGF
et le CGEDD il permet déclencher
réellement une acquisition que dans 15 %
des cas il ne permet pas d'accéder au
crédit pour les plus modestes les
banques apprécie la solevabilité des
emperateurs de la même façon que pour
les autres prêts il déclenche
d'importants effets artificialisants
dans les zones détendues l'article 6 du
PLF 2024 prévoit de proroger le PTZ
jusqu'en 2027 alors qu'il devrait
s'arrêter il devait s'arrêter fin 2023
tout le recentrant en zone tendue sur
les imbles collectifs et en zone non
tendue sur les immeubles anciens sous
condition de travau de rénovation le
rapport du C salue ce recentrage en ce
qu'il permettra de limiter les effets
artifisation du
dispositif
sur la question de l'objectif de
révision des des bases c'est pas de
stimuler l'investissement immobilier
mais de rétablir une équité entre
contribuables sur la révision des bases
locatives ça profitera je l'ai déjà dit
aux habitants des banlieux et des
départements
ruraux sur
la
TLV le rapport est favorable à une
extension géographique de la TLV les
évolutions récente du zonage de la TLV
intervenue dans le cadre du décret d'O
2023 sont une avancé dans cette
direction cette extension réduit le
champ de la TH élevé puisque les deux
taxes sont alternatives mécaniquement ça
permet aux communes concerné d'instituer
une majoration de thrrs le CPO n'a pas
instruit la possibilité d'une fusion
entre ces trois fiscalités qui
seorteraient à les difficultés qui sera
peut-être pas insurmontable mais qui
mérite une étude très approfondie pour
ce qui est euh
de j'arrive au bout sur l'investissement
locatif euh le dispositif d Pinel est
une réduction d'impôts pour les
investissement locatif dans le 9 sous
certaines conditions il a été introduit
par la euh loi de finance initiale pour
2015 pour favoriser la construction de
logement intermédiaire privé il fait
suite à d'autres régimes que j'ai déjà
évoqué le celler du flot et CEER il a
été modifié et recentré à quatre
reprises euh nous pensons qu'il est
pertinent de ne pas reconduire ce
dispositif après son extinction prévue
en 2024 parce que pour le dire d'un mot
il est à nos yeux coûteux et peu
efficace alors parmi les dispit de
remplacement on peut citer le statut du
propriétaire bailleur consistant des
aides en contrepartie d'un plafonnement
de loyer ou de ressources qui engagerait
les finances publiques sur le long terme
voilà euh la génération du Pinel breton
consistant à limiter un zonage
infracommunal nous pensons qu'il y a pas
plus d'élargir les dispositif de
fiscalisation outre M prévu par
l'article 199 un des CS A du code
général des impôts relatif à
l'investissement
locatif merci on va passer aux questions
supplémentaire il y en a pas mal ce qui
montre l'intérêt de la commission
évidemment pour le sujet votre rapport
euh Monsieur Daniel Labaronne pour une
minute merci monsieur le Président merci
monsur depuis une dizaine d'années le
pouvoir d'achat immobilier n'a cessé de
baisser y compris lorsque les taux
d'intérêts étaient bas c'est encore plus
vrai aujourd'hui quand les taux sont
élevés monsieur le Président comment
expliquez-vous que les prix de de
l'immobilier n'arrivent pas à baisser
alors même que la demande chute et que
les taux d'intérêt augmentent or il
existe une loi en finance qui s'applique
aujourd'hui dans la plupart des pays
européens mais pas en France qui veut
que lorsque les taux d'intérêt
augmentent le prix des actifs mobiliers
et immobiliers baisse est-ce que
fondamentalement il n'y aurait pas dans
la fiscalité un facteur éminemment
inflationniste je vous
remercie merci on va alterner les
groupes Fabien di
Filippo il est parti
d'accord alors Marina
Ferrari comment mais je l'avais aussi
compé jeanpa non ah c'est Jean-Paul
matille alors ah d'accord comme vous
voulez Jean-Paul
mat bien ouis mais moi j'ai au fur à
mesure que j'écrit merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président de
la Cour des comptes ce rapport nous nous
permet effectivement de de mener une
réflexion qu'il faut j'aimerais bien
qu'elle passe à la face active sur la
réforme de la fiscalité de de
l'immobilier l'immobilier on le sait est
très taxé maltraité par notre fiscalité
IFI revenus
fonciers taxes foncière euh je suis un
peu étonné dans votre rapport donc sur
la préconisation de de taxer à la place
des droits de mutation de taxer les
stocks le grand débat c'est la taxation
entre la taxation des stocks et la
taxation des flux et je crois que euh
cette idée de dire queon va remplacer
les droits de mutation par une taxe
augmenter va à l'encontre de ce qu'on
peut faire je vous rappelle que les
droits de mutation sont payés par les
acquéreurs que ces droits de mutation
sont plus ou moins financés dans un car
de plan de financement et qui s'étale
dans le temps si vous mettez une taxe je
dirais là on
va toucher au pouvoir d'achat des
ménages qui n'auront pas financé grâce à
l'emprunt donc moi je j'avoue que je
suis troublé sur cette proposition et je
suis également assez troublé par le fait
que et je vous remercie de retenir la
proposition sur la réforme des PL
immobilière mais il faut impérativement
qu'on trouve des moyens je dirais de de
remplacer justement la taxation des
plusvalu immobilière par cette taxe sur
les droits d'enregistrement parce que ce
sont pas les mêmes personnes qui le
paient c'est l'acquéreur qui paye les
droits d'enregistrement et et c'est le
vendeur qui P les plus-values
immobilières et je pense que là on a une
piste Christine PZ euh non Christine
pirezbon SICI oui merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président du
CPO et merci à tous ceux et toutes
celles qui ont contribué à ce à ce
rapport et moi je vais vous parler d'un
rapport publié en 2018 où le CPO
s'étonné que la fiscalité française des
revenus locatif présente deux
particularités en Europe la seule
indistingué location nu et location
meublée la seule avec le Luxembourg à
permettre dans le régime de la location
meublée l'imposition de la plus-value
sans réintégration des amortissements
pratiqués en cours de de détention vous
indiquiez à cette époque la perte de
recettes d'environ 330 à 380 millions d'
par
an et vous préconisiez alors
l'unification du régime fiscal et des
locations meublées et celui des location
nu janvier 2018 décembre 2023 6 ans et
toujours rien j'ajoute que lors du
dernier PLF le rapporteur général et
moi-même nous avions à ce sujet déposé
des amendements alors j'ai une question
simple estce que vous avez un remède à
la procrastination de la
majorité une autre question 70 fiscale
relative au logement c'est vous vous
l'écrivez dans ce dans votre diaporama
et concernant la location vous faites
état de l'exonération d'impôt sur le
revenu pour les personnes louant en
meublé merci c'est la seule dans votre
tableau qui n'est pas chiffré est-ce que
vous savez pourquoi merci merci emmeric
Salmond pour le
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président du du conseil je souhaite vous
poser une question sur un sujet qui
n'est pas abordé dans votre rapport mais
qui revient régulièrement notamment
l'INC a publié un article hier sur le
sujet c'est la taxation des loyers
imputés c'estàd que les loyers que les
propriétaires auraient payé s'ils ne
sont s'ils n'étaient pas propriétaires
s'ils étaient locataires je souhaiterais
avoir l'avis du CPO sur ce sujet est-ce
que c'est un sujet que le CPO envisage
de d'étudier à l'avenir et env qu'elleve
la position du CPO sur ce point je vous
remercie merci Michel Castellani pour
Liot
ouais merci président merci Monsieur
président pour pour ce rapport très très
très très fouillé de regret d'abord
regret que l'évolution de la fiscalité
et réduit les ressources des
collectivités bien sûr regret aussi que
le logement serve de variable
d'ajustement on pourrait discuter
longtemps sur l'opportunité ou pas de de
supprimer le
Pinel par contre oui à la recommandation
6 d'ouvrir le PTZ au logement ancien en
zone tendue avec travaux oui à la
recommandation 10 de rapprocher
d'unifier les régimes fiscaux de de
location meublé avec location par contre
on peut discuter à l'infini de la
recommandation numéro 8 c'est-à-dire de
de de favoriser des mutation et de taxer
davantage le la détention de
de de logement je dirais oui et non moi
je rappelle qu'encore il y a 39 % de
résident secondaire une mutation c'est
des couples qui s'installent bien sûr
mais une mutation c'est aussi des
résidences
d'été qui qui qui change complètement le
fond d'une société donc
ENF on peut discuter beaucoup de cette
recommandation 8 merci merci Véronique
louvagi pour oui merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président merci beaucoup pour cette
présentation monsieur le Président du
CPU effectivement sur cette
recommandation numéro 8 est-ce que à un
moment donné nous ne sommes pas dans une
situation un petit peu utopique et de
long terme puisque vous le dites très
justement d'ailleurs il faut d'abord
mettre en cohérence la fiscalité avec la
valeur économique des des logements donc
l'envisager oui mais est-ce que c'est
possible à à court terme voilà deuxème
point également sur la situation du
viager est-ce que c'est un mode
d'acquisition qui vous paraîtrait
pouvoir convenir aujourd'hui moi je
trouve que c'est un dispositif qui n'est
pas beaucoup utilisé et qui pourrait
permettre aujourd'hui à des personnes de
rénover finalement leur logement au
travers le bénéfice de ce qu'on appelle
le bouquet je parle sous le contrôle des
du du du notaire et de bénéficier de
revenus ensuite et et c'est un
dispositif qui peut paraître désués mais
mais qui pour autant pourrait être une
alternative donc est-ce que c'est un
mode d'acquisition ou un mode de gestion
de patrimoine que vous avez étudié je
vous remercie merci Charles systens tool
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Président je tiens à saluer
comme beaucoup de collègues le le
travail important du Conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires sur la
fiscalité du logement et vous dressez
effectivement un constat du gaspillage
d'argent public dans cette politique
alors et c'est bien le paradoxe de la
France que nos concitoyens éprouvent de
plus en plus de difficultés à se loger
acheter trouver une maison ou un
appartement et territoire où je suis élu
en centrale n'est pas exent de ces
difficultés je souscris à votre idée de
réorienter les aides en direction de
l'acquisition de l'ancien et plus
largement d'une grande réforme du
soutien public à la politique du
logement ma question sera la suivante
sur sur la liste des dépenses fiscales
relatives au logement que vous dressez
dans ce rapport lesquels vous semblent
avoir le plus mauvais ratio coût
efficacité dit autrement lesquels vous
semblent les plus urgentes à à à
corriger merci Marina Ferrari merci
messieur les présidents alors moi j'ai
une question en trois temps la première
concerne donc la fiscalité des revenus
fonciers qui peut apparaître en France
relativement confiscatoire faut-il selon
vous la rénover la simplifier pour
rendre l'investissement locatif plus
attractif imaginons par exemple la mise
en place du neu flat taxe qui était une
proposition également portée par le
président mat sur la question des
microbies et micronciers donc si tout le
monde s'accorde pour le le sur le fait
qu'il faut lutter contre la trtion du
logement permanent en revanche il y a
dans le régime microfoncier deux régimes
celui du meublé classé et celui du
meublé non classé avez-vous évalué
l'impact que pourrait avoir un phénomène
de déclassement de des meublés classés
sur l'activité touristique des
territoires et sur les stations classées
de tourisme puisque c'est un point
d'attention particulière je vous
rappelle qu'on a
98500 seulement foyers fiscaux qui
bénéficie de l'abattement de 71 % versus
515000 donc ne nous trompons pas de
cible et enfin dernier point vous avez
euh évoqué la question des plus-values
sur les les durées de
détention en revanche il y a en ce
moment qui tourne la question des
plus-values la réintégration de
l'amortissement dans les plus-values qui
tourne dans nos discussions budgétaires
moi j'ai une inquiétude sur le sujet par
rapport au modèle de de résidence de
tourisme de résidence étudiante ou de
résidence senior euh avez-vous pu
évaluer les choses si on intégrait enfin
quel pourrait être l'impact de ce genre
de mesure je vous remercie merci
et enfin franc alisio
r merci monsieur le
Président le la fiscalité sur
l'immobilier sur le logement en France
est trois fois plus élevée qu'en
Allemagne donc c'est évident qu'il faut
faire un lien entre la crise du logement
actuel et la la fiscalité record et donc
il faut baisser cette fiscalité autant
sur les détenteurs que sur les
acquéreurs on parle de CSG sensiblement
majoré tax droit de succession droit de
mutation impô sur le revenu parfois
IFI cette fiscalité ne contribue
évidemment pas à l'ajustement du du
marché cette fiscalité est évidemment
inflationniste quand on voit compare à
l'Allemagne toujours que l'Allemagne a
une fiscalité très raisonnable et du
coup des prix et des loyers beaucoup
plus raisonnables que les nôres ma
question est simple quelle mesure
préconisez-vous en la matière afin de de
faire de mettre un terme aux raquettes
fiscales des propriétaires merci et donc
la parole est à vous monsieur le
Président bien je je
commencerai je encore une fois pas
reprendre les les réponses que j'ai déjà
faites je commencerai par le facteur
inflctioniste de la fiscalité pour dire
que oui euh je partage votre analyse
nous estimons que la fiscalité contribue
à rigidifier les les prix en France plus
qu'ailleurs mais ce n'est pas le seul et
ce n'est même pas le principal facteur
autrement dit il faut analyser ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui une part de mystère
parce que de toute façon assez logique
avec l'offre et la demande les prix
devraient baisser fortement pourquoi ne
baisset-il pas il y a des comportements
à la fois du côté de l'offre et du côté
de la demande du côté à la fois de ceux
qui veulent acheter et qui ne le peuvent
pas cont du cou du crédit du côté de
ceux qui détiennent les bien qui ne le
vendent pas qui méritent peut-être des
analyes plus fouillé mais ça peut pas
durer éternellement ça c'est une opinion
on peut vivre sur ses stocks sur son
épargne pendant un certain temps au bout
d'un moment ça devient un peu plus
difficile mais nous verrons mais il faut
analyser les choses plus en profondeur
c'est le secteur immobilier connaît un
retourement depuis que la BCE a
enclenché la remontée des taux en
juillet 22 donc c'est très clair c'est à
ce moment-là qu'il y a le point
d'inflexion le crédit
immobilier septembre 2023 avait chuté en
valeur de 45 % sur un an le nombre de
transactions de 18 % pour s'établir à
928000 sur un an à la fin 2023 euh ça
intervient après une longue période de
prospérité cet ajustement était sans
doute nécessaire parce qu'on pouvait pas
vivre éternellement sur des régimes de
taux bas voir négatif mais le problème
c'est la question de l'atterrissage euh
de ce point de vue la stabilisation des
taux de la BCE les dernières mesures
pris par le ha conseil de la stabilité
financière pour frudifier le droit de
crédit vont dans le bon sens et je
constate que le montant des crédits
accordés c'est d'ailleurs stabilisé en
octobre en revanche aucune mesure
fiscale n'empêchera la crise si les prix
ne baissent pas donc je je renverse un
petit peu la problématique qui est la
vre pas contradictoire d'ailleurs et
c'est pour ça que le rapport du CPO en
fait n'est pas un rapport de conjoncture
je il se place dans une plque
structurelle il ne propose pas car il ne
l'a pas de REM miracle à court terme qui
ne ferait qu'aggraver la CRÉ suivante
donc évitons le choc fiscal làdessus
c'est globalement inefficace coûteux et
ça crée une nouvelle distorsion il
s'inscrit dans le temps long parce que
c'est un secteur qui a besoin de
stabilité visibilité et comme je le
disais dans mon introduction le rapport
recommande de renforcer la neutralité de
la fiscalité du logement pour rendre le
secteur plus résilient à l'avenir pour
faire que le marché soit plus fluide et
pour éviter qu'on connaisse à nouveau ce
type de mécanisme c'est ça la logique
effectivement ça présage des évolutions
relativement imprévisibles dans les
temps qui viennent pour ce qui
concerne les remarques sur la taxation
des stocks et des flux fait par Monsieur
mat comment vous dire nous assumons euh
c'est qu'effectivement ce que favorise
le rapport vise à favoriser ce rapport
c'est bien l'accession et la mobilité
oui nous pensons qu'il faut je le redis
pour la 1è fois t davantage la rente que
la mobilité le mouvement la rénovation
et et c'est le sens de ce rapport in
contestablement je je redis ce ce
chiffre final
euh quant à la bascule de des DMTO vers
la TFB j'ajouterai aux autres arguments
que j'ai déjà donné que les taxes sur
les transactionsob en France sont parmi
les plus élevés de l'OCDE ce qui
pénalise la mobilité résidentielle et
l'accès au logement mais encore une fois
nous avons déposé cet objet devant vous
naturellement c'est à vous dans décider
ultérieurement même si je le redis aussi
en réponse à Madame louvagi
euh forcément tout ça ne peut-être que
progressif et nous disons d'ailleurs que
que la révision de l'assiette est un
préalable tout doit être pensé en même
temps simultanément faire l'un sans
faire l'autre dans un sens comme dans
l'autre d'ailleurs n'est pas tout à fait
logique euh j'ai expliqué en quoi nous
proposions de revenir et approfondir sur
les propositions de votre rapport avec
celui de Nicolas sensu monsieur le
député sur les loyers implicites
jusqu'en 65 la France taxait les loyers
implicites des propriétes occupant dit
également imputé c'est un système qui
présente de multiples
difficultés
et le CPO s'est prononcé contre le
rétablissement de ce système dans son
rapport de 2018 sur euh les prélèvements
sur le capital des ménages et il
renouvelle son opposition à ce
dispositif dans le présent rapport une
étude de lcé vient quein vient de
publier il valu seend à 7 % du revenue
national net le montant des loyers
imputés net leors non imposition
constituant des dépenses fiscal caché
qui peut aller jusqu'à 11 milliards
d'euros par an et ça profite
principalement au ménag âgés et les plus
riches et donc nous sommes prêts à
travailler sur ce sujet si par exemple
votre commission n le demandons je pense
c'est un un vrai vrai beau sujet
sur la suppression
du du régime du LMNP ça a été chiffré en
2018 à 350 millions d'euros n'ont pas en
effet été en mesure d'actualiser ce
système il y a pas d'élément sur le
viager dans ce rapport
euh
sur la loi Pinel
euh n pensons que c'est vraiment pour le
coup la plus mauvaise dépense fiscale
dont le coût est de 1,3 milliard d'euros
euh avec un effet inflationniste et donc
nous encourageons à ne pas prolonger
cela euh enfin sur les dépenses
fiscales je dis ça parce que nous
n'avons pas de réponse à vos questions
madame je suis désolé je me suis tourné
vers l'équipe mais pas traiter ces
questions dans le rapport simplement sur
les dépenses fiscales lesquelles me
demandait monsieur le
député on a fait une note structurelle
qui montrait le nombre l'ampleur 90
milliards d'euros de dépenses fiscales
on le voit sur cet exemple précis 70
milliards 15 milliards je pense que ça
fait typiquement partie des revues de
dépenses qui doivaient impérativement
être faites pour préparer de manière
intelligente le PLF 2025 qui sera
compliqué parce que celui de 2024 euh
repose essentiellement on va pas
l'apprécier ici
sur
la levée de dépenses qui ne sont pas
structurelles qui étai conjoncturell et
qui ont été prolonger longemps mais je
vous confirme une chose aux uns et aux
autres le quoi qu'il en goûte c'est fini
c'està-dire que le que ça ce que oui
mais vous ne pourrez plus on ne pourra
plus le faire en 2025 pour le coup ça
devient vraiment résiduel donc il faut
passer à autre chose et effectivement
les dépenses fiscales voilà c'est un des
sujets qu'il faut évaluer la Cour des
comptes ne sa'est pas livrer l'exercice
elle peut aussi le faire
nous sommes en discussion avec le
gouvernement sur la façon dont nous
pouvons contribuer le plus utilement à
ces rebus de dépenses et nous sommes
tout à fait volontaire pour le faire
alors excusez-moi mais j'avais Fabien di
Filippo qui éit inscrit donc je permet
de poser sa question et voulez-vous
poser question ou pas allez-y allez-y
non mais allez-y allez-y je c'est Noël
donc allez-y c'est Noël pour tout le
monde et bien je dois dire un grand
grand merci au Père Noël ma question en
fait portait sur le ciblage des aid que
vous abordez dans une partie de la de la
de la présentation et alors à à deux
niveaux on a eu on voit qu'il y a une
concentration dans notre pays de plus en
plus grande et vous me direz si
mathématiquement c'est vérifié ou pas
entre ceux qui payent les impôts et ceux
qui touchent les aides et ça se sépare
de plus en plus il y a eu la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation qui é un impôt
local payé bah par tous ceux qui résidit
et compensé par de la TVA et aujourd'hui
on nous dit bah la TVA est très très
dynamique dont les communes vont devoir
faire des efforts il y a ce problème-là
et sur les aides ciblées dont vous
parlez vous dites elles doivent être
encore plus ciblées le problème c'est
que les personnes qui ont les moyens de
faire ces travaux et de faire les
travaux d'ampleur notamment en matière
de rénovation énergétique et bien elles
touchent de moins en moins d'aide elles
sont de moins en moins incité à le à le
faire au au niveau au niveau économique
et donc est-ce qu'il faudrait pas et
bien financer davantage des plus gros
travaux à ceux qui ont les moyens de
construire de conduire de grands projets
et des plus petits travaux à ceux qui
qui ont de qui ont des moyens plus plus
faible une échelle de modulation un peu
différente pour éviter cette fracture
vraiment entre ceux qui et bien ont
l'impression de tout payer et ceux qui
bénéfici des aides de l'autre côté sans
payer d'impôt aujourd'hui ben monsieur
le député c'est en effet la la logique
du rapport parce que ce que nous
concédons constatons c'est le constat 4
et 5 du rapport c'est qu'en effet il y a
une distorsion majeure entre le taux
d'effort après aide au logement et la
part des taxes en revenu du revenu en
pourcent du revenu et donc l'ensemble du
rapport vise à Rist cela et à faire en
sorte que on rétablisse la valeur
économique et le lien
entre ceux qui payent et ceux qui
bénéficient bien donc on clot là-dessus
merci monsieur le Président merci au CPO
de manière
générale en commission en tout cas c'est
la clôture je vous rappelle qu'on se
retrouve le 16 janvier pour une audition
de Carole delg pour les régions de
inaugure un cyle de audition qu'on va
faire de tous les représentants des
collectivités locales et le 17 janvier
on a une audition Inc banque defance
OCDE voilà bonne fête à
tous le 16 janvier c'est après les QAG
bonne fête à tous merci